over here literally just got back from
Australia like a matter of hours ago we
he's after Glenn Powell and Sydney
Sweeney fueled even more dating rumors
at cinemacon the source tells E.T the
actor and his girlfriend Gigi Paris
called it quits I feel like so much of
this year was just trying to keep my
head above water Glenn and Gigi began
dating in 2019. she's the best and my
family loves her and approves fast
forward to April and our store says the
couple broke up after three years
together and that the split was amicable
confirming that Glenn is now single can
we confirm that yeah the relationship
update comes after eagle-eyed fans
noticed the model unfollowed him on
Instagram Gigi also dropped this cryptic
Instagram reel Gigi wrote in the caption
know your worth and on to the next but
Glenn he still follows her I think
that's the best thing that I've realized
in my life is I get very uncomfortable
when it's about me when I can make it
about the person I'm playing or or my
family or or the movie or my co-stars
rumors of a breakup started swirling
amid glance press tour for his upcoming
rom-com anyone but you co-starring
Sydney it's like hard to have a bad time
in Australia we um we did like so many
activities Sydney was like our social
chair we had an activity every weekend
that everybody went out and did the duo
made an appearance at cinemacon this
week their on-screen chemistry on full
display Sydney joked she calls Glenn Top
Gun he answered I love when she calls me
that this guy needs an ego check fans
began wondering if that chemistry was
also translating off-screen especially
after this cozy video hit the internet
[Music]
go fast our source says that the dating
rumors couldn't be further from the
truth not only are they not dating but
Sydney still very much engaged to fiance
Jonathan devino yeah so Glenn and
Sydney's real life rom-com energy is
only for the big screen anyone but use
release date is still TBD but Glenn
tease is why it'll be worth the wait I
don't know about you but I feel like
this is like not only do we go for the
hard R which is really really fun but
it's also like when was the last time
you saw like a hard R rom-com that's big
and it's cinematic everybody's in
swimsuits looking good
[Music]
thank you